the category is directing and this year
the nominees tackled a wide variety of
subject matter with skill and creativity
the nominees for best achievement in
directing are Woody Allen for bullets
over Broadway
robert zemeckis for forrest gump Quentin
Tarantino for Pulp Fiction
Robert Redford for cui show and
Christoph Kozlowski for red
and the Oscar goes to Alex your father
just won the Academy Award robert
zemeckis for Forrest Gump
Oh
it is so incredible that Stephen is
handing me this this great trophy so I
guess I can't think of a more
appropriate place or time to say Thank
You Stephen thank you for believing me
in me and giving me my start for being a
guiding influence in my work and being a
good friend thank you very much there
are some others who have contributed
greatly to my career my parents of
course I also like to thank Jack rapke
Bruce Raymer John Milius and Bob Gale
and for this tremendous honor I'd like
to thank the members of the Academy
everyone at Paramount Pictures my entire
cast and crew for doing a job that
amazed me every day and made it an
incredible joy to go to work
- Wendy fine Ehrman for bringing this
project to me and getting it started in
the first place for Steve Starkey for
making sure we got it finished Tom Hanks
and Eric Roth my creative soul mates
it's obvious this film could not have
been made without your huge talent most
important I'd like to thank my wife Mary
Ellen and my son Alex for your love
support for being my main source of
inspiration not only in my work but in
my life and finally I would like to
thank motion picture audiences all
around the world in historic numbers you
have embraced a film that added at its
heart offers a human life affirming
hopeful story thank you very much